bonjour monsieur peut monter dans une
voiture fantastique
[Musique]
toi tu roules cannes comme en brulhois
bon écoute j'aime bien j'aime bien la
vitesse et c'est quoi je crois que la
vitesse d'un bien bon alors il dit je
vous explique ici les idées fiscaux la
casse qui s'est passé skoda m'a dit
monsieur revient nous voir on va te
faire relever des défis
tu vas voir un animateur talentueux
énervé qui serai avec toi qui vas te
mettre au challenge
donc les nids fiscaux d'art l'idée c'est
à tenir à me concentrer taux qui roule
comme d'accord donc les défis skoda on
est parti sur un circuit l'idée c'était
de devenir challenger le stack est un
coureur émérite un pilote émérite qui
roule à toi j'ai roulé comme un vrai
boulot et du coup il a fallu rouler sur
le circuit avec pas un moment de
l'hybride par moments de l'électrique
exact switcher les deux semaines chez
entre les deux pas toujours pas toujours
hyper hyper simple vaches pas toujours
hyper hyper simple mais toujours
sympathique on s'arrête mais plus âpres
en charge et attentionné ce qu on peut
quand même me tuer je scrute au switch
allez on passe des petites chicanes un
peu comme celle là tu vas pas cela la
chicane où tu vas
le club d'origine donc on passe les
chicanes et on voit là on doit relever
il ya un chrono en fait ya le stade qui
a déjà fait les tours avant moi ensuite
ya un mois et puis voilà alors l'idée
derrière tout ça devient lourde mais
caméra là l'idée derrière tout ça c'est
effectivement de venir parler de skoda
de venir à parler de kylie de ces
derrières de parler de ce qu'on a de
montrer ce qu'on est capable de faire
avec une voiture ici c'est l'hybride et
et sa sa tartine du feu de dieu tu
oublies pas là bas c'est dangereux et ça
s'oublie pas c'est hyper dangereux là
enfin jérôme c'est hyper dangereux s'il
fait hier ses parents
donc voilà donc en fait et je vais pas
vous donner le sport j'ai pas vous dire
mais par contre je vous dis registre un
truc que le besoin de vous tout de suite
maintenant et surtout que vous alliez
dans la vidéo et que vous me lâcher les
commentaires un max de commentaires
j'ai perdu ma mort
[Musique]
donc il faut que vous aviez dans le lien
dans la 2 x au prix que vous mettiez un
commentaire oh je vous mets tout ce que
vous voulez mais vous le mettez moi
parce que ça mais comme tu mais sinon
voila voila ca les défis skoda c'est
beau c'est sympa c'est avec jérôme qui
veut ma mort
tth mais tu as déjà fait du circuit
avant d'en territoire jamais tu atteins
vrais parisiens ont battu conduit à
paris donc voilà alesi dans la
description vous cliquez sur le lien
vous allez voir l'élite et fils que là
mais vous me laissez des commentaires
parce qu'il faut que je marque des
points s'il n'y a pas de commentaire il
n'y a pas assez de poids j'ai besoin de
commentaire j'ai besoin de vous et j'ai
besoin de fichiers la question des
chikhates maintenant voilà ce que témoin
bon courage merci à vous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo si je la preuve c'est que je
suis vivant merci jérôme merci à toi et
herisau pas prévu de poche pour le vomi
attention c'est le dernier virage qui
est un peu serré la [ __ ] si tu connais
maintenant on va finir dans le bac à
sable
il
mais
[Musique]